oh he's gone there he goes
with a one-timer and he scored
helmet on a power play goal look at the
Blue Line made a great play Crosby the
touch cancel by the captain he's still he
scores Sydney Crosby [Music] his pass block
he gets to Puck again back to Queen
Hughes Patterson lets it go he scores
93 mile an hour swap shot Canucks are three for
four on the power plan for their largest lead of
the game off ice Michael walks in shot score jack
eichel off the posted in and the golden knights
have blown it open in Minnesota church trying
to keep the pressure all puts out into two on oh
connection
and Caprice [Applause] could I just have
to tucked over the goalie in the bench
here's Hughes dropping back Miller shoots he
scores JT Miller with six attackers on the
ice on a delayed penalty 44 on the year
to McDavid open his back home to the net
we are tied at four brought to you by your
Tri-State Volkswagen dealers [Applause]
back on the ice for Florida foreswick
finds Pettit plus size [Applause] [Music]
Byron rotates for McKinnon stutter step side
steps done Auto McKinnon scores Nathan McCann
a super attacker on Yamamoto giving way
McDavid dry shuttle shoots and scores
convenient a sliver of daylight
back to the point for Petrie
Zucker fires he scores Jason Zucker the blast two
nothing Pittsburgh four in a row against the team
that won the President's Cup last year radish with
a shot score off a pass at the blue line and the
Hawks strike on the power play this and stay here
so there's a great chance right off the face off
the score Victor Olson buried that one with a
one-timer the duck there's no bunchkin to the
roof Alex Ovechkin brings the cats within one doc
over the line it's a three on two that shot score
Mike Hoffman OT winner as the halves
open up the road trip with a big win 3-2
Wicked shot to break and scores
Shockley comes over to help and
time for Morrissey to walk
of course he shoots scores
two in a row now hulak loading up McDavid
a tribe scores this game is tied for all
looks cross ice Montour Waits walks
in hammers what score [Applause]
here he comes
[Applause]
it up top done
power play goal already from forsberg for the
Press Yoshi score a rocket to make it two nothing
wow Londale on the loose Puck here's white in
the [__] he scores Colin white as his first
as a panther what a rocket and we're tied at one
his shot get away picked up by punching back up
top scores [Applause] [Music] here's radish he
scores what an individual effort by Garen radish
there's windrim now for Fox now to
return for Lindgren shoots two scores
and into the boards hard had to give way that's
Jack Johnson down there he had
it stolen Sherwood [Applause]
pass intended for Fairview but ericksonac
was there an outlet to Johansson
brings it across finds the trailer Baldi shoots
[Applause]
Rodriguez shoots and scores Evan
Rodriguez Tyler Johnson to radish
great exit by the Hawks leading to
a rush now radish Caleb Jones scores
the defenseman Caleb Jones up
in the play Anderson [Applause]
first as a Montreal Canadian in Montreal with
life it's 3-2 but it went off to Plumbing that
comes Eagles it'll drop pass he gets it back
and he scores short side on Lucan this ski is
just so deceptive and back on Tuesday normally
that role is occupied by John Carlson Sherry
close to strong rips it upstairs he scores
Dylan strong pulled down by McCord shoots
it's blocked gets it back now McKinnon looking
again shoots and scores Nathan man cut it with
a beautiful wrist shot riff you could feel it
coming by very Trot score Kevin Hayes [Music]
makes a good save there Nick Paul takes that
puck off the draw works it down the ice leaves
of her stand goes in shoes [Applause] him
hitting that Defender first gives him some
time [Applause] [Music] John Merrill
playing his first game of the season
his third of the Year coverage problems doesn't
like what he sees has to cut back headers are
right now for Zucker he scores he scores
Jason suffer with the blast I'm Bob Circa
jab now across to hago and shoot scores
Brendan haga with a power play goal two
goals in regulation here he comes Nick
Dowd closing down on the feed one time
with a BB to Win It 4-3 Washington
by Logan Thompson another opportunity
[Applause] Los Angeles as it's fumbled by
Carter for Hagee who had that shot my bad
and Manny veneers up top cranks it right by
brovsky game speed through neutralize tries
to weave his way and he's still on takes the
shot but Gibson has to save Barbara puts it up
top there's the blasting Carlton he scores thank
you Mr Stevenson drops it back to Theodore scores
[Music] here's Caulfield sends it up top Savard
beautiful shot from the youngster is Kate and
ghoulie lets it Fly that right guys because
his performance drives him a rocket from hola
barkov again over the Blue Line centering feed
Montour Scott for Haiti snapshot score remember
hanging second of the game and the Panthers get
the lead late in the second Johnny Gordon
back for done done for Gord again High slug
Tolman scores that's hockey Baby James Thompson
over on this near side one timer's gone he is
caprisov got a piece of it 15. [Music]
said it keeps the puck alive the truck with a
shot he scores Matthew could chuck with 12 and
7 10 seconds remaining by Brody Brody late to the
middle Matthew scores Austin Matthews find a soft
spot his swap shot stayed along the ice there's
Crosby [Applause] back across the Malkin will turn
[Music]
it's time cousins just over the line
Thompson far Circle breaks the back
of the net with that one practically as
he lets it rip his second of the game
taking a look [Applause] his second of
the game has the Oilers back in it the
job lets it get sorted out next live
jumping up on the back side [Music]
scores
4-1 Rangers number 17 for Vladimir Tarasenko runs
from steps up through Center Calio touch paders he
shot score last night from Sean Jersey and then
Blake knocks it by Amir here's a break for Blake
in on goal shoots and he Stars Sammy Blade with
a great play Michael snaps it up ahead Marshall
into the Zone with Barbershop marches the looking
and he scored Jonathan marches though snaps at
home he'll find step on step on leaves it for
Chatfield chat filters on the screen and scores
alien Chatfield punch your ticket
trip the canes have tied it at one
way out of Chuck keeping it alive Carlo
can't grab it it comes to berhagy turn
ER the way the Drone can find guys I think
they'll continue to build chemistry as you
know you go year to year it scores get
shots It Off The Rush with the second
power play unit here's Max Domi speak of
the devil Domi with a burst [Applause]
Chuck up to Patterson panthersin Drakes it scores
Craig Patterson what a shot top Corner
traffic Frost picks it up numbers for
the Flyers man rimsych is joining so
is Tiffin here's front with a shot
back around an awesome Cattery from the corner
throws a sharp angle shot they score thousand
Connery top corner now the blades up 4-1 nylander
in the slot Riley Matthews scores a blast from the
Rocket Richard Trophy winner again setting towards
the front of the net Boyd's got it and now ritzy
is that in light one on as we'll continue on if
it went in we'll hear the horn gostisbearer with
a shot that's ripped wide I thought that was ball
take it pass on to the left wing Skinner tried to
buy some space for Thompson with a shot scores
TNT put some mustard on that one up for Yes for
Boston Chatfield with it the field turns on the
speed gets it back to turn by and he's gone hello
[Applause] [Music]
now Sagan it will speed his hands gets around
and scores what a goal by rope hits and Dallas
with a one-nothing lead coming up with Sharon in
transition Perron for Larkin [Applause] [Music]
whoa baby to the wall now forced by Schwartz
McCann still Star Wars [Applause] [Music]
for Sandy for Matthews with room
walks in fire scores [Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
welcome back Patrick Lainey and yeah welcome back
to Winnipeg one-nothing Columbus ashes are too
elected to Ransom in behind the net [Music] for
the long timer and there it is a power play of
gold by Kale mccar th comes Tavaris knee Landers
on the Move William knee lager busting in scores
two on one with Fowler if they hurry
ziegress fights off a Defender oh [Applause]
Alex stuck nice move off
the wall for domain scores
good offensive zone time here as Rosie's gone back
with Rosie Scott finds it Coleman shoots Scott
Stars [Music] [Applause] promise gets it
back Draco now for Letty tough angle shot
from the corner a brilliant shot and it's
2-1 seconds left on the minor to delaurier
Josh Bailey across the line
for Parisi [Applause] [Music]
tonight for Zach Parisi he's in this
hockey game but from the shark standpoint
a lot of them haven't resulted in shots on
goal maybe this will Myers shoots head score
scores that one found the net for Timo Meyer
nylander up high trying to step away from
detecting approber off tomorrow [Applause]
[Music] to the point and McCabe in
front score hard cave gets the Hawks
out to a 1-0 lead it's gassed right
now Skinner Far Side what time is gone
[Applause]
Paul Berry shoots had one earlier 40 had a second
and Parisi with an opportunity crossbar looks like
it goes off the camera and then out clearly so
now they will determine when that puck go and
the stamp goes penalty for tripping nice play eye
and it gathers the puck in and skipping on about
the zipper right in front all the way over and the
shots goes on the power play at 2-1 egg holds it
Stone drifting into the corner hey for
the one time and he scores in overtime
before and then Davis what a feed here's captain
and he scores what a shot and it's three nothing
he is just playing the best hockey I've seen
as a New Jersey Devil now Ryan Graves lets
it going he's [Applause] oh my along with it
and Terry prize it from him makes a pass heft
in front it goes all the way throughout to the
point snapped over Secrets he scores [Applause]
at Detroit he had three goals last season in
75 games almost had a huge one now they have
the game-winning goal Boston wins
it in overtime is last night he's
got four points in the last three
games here's a shot by Lady scores
Patrick Lainey looks at the crowd tied for the
NHL lead six goals wrist shot that one is blocked
in fact it broke the Stick of luceranian so he
has to go to the bench one timer stamp goes are
Twinkle Twinkle Little Star that's for New Jersey
just 12 for Philadelphia nice play by Kevin Hayes
ripped and score [Applause] Travis connectny great
play NLP Lowry going to left yeah fire scores
Neil pioch his second of a nine is
the overtime winner the ABS are in a
good Groove winning five straight
strome settles back to robotkin
a blast from the capital
Captain it's a one goal game
[Applause]
this shot goes wide lots more pressure
by the San Jose Sharks Polo scores
off his back foot a bullet three shots
others I don't know how malgan did not score
that goal that was a beautiful Passover Rico
was in shoots off the post on got it
or did it go in it did ratchet in Fox
looking out to paneran to Savannah Jenny scores
[Applause] Mika's a better job brush it down low
kuznetsa strobe that oh she fires off the
inside he scores TJ Oshie sit on the line
[Music] [Applause] one timer now it's the Penguins
turret Crosby gets all the two on one against
the looks fires he scores Jake getzel has just
brought the house down [Applause] shoot scores
[Applause] knocked down but
comes to klingberg he's gone
she drops it off the topoli honor to Foley
Rasmus Anderson scores Anderson in overtime
crossbar down Flames win 3-2 00 back tonight turns
it over and there's a score Colts assistance goes
upstairs Brendan because you're right people
are coming at you hard they're paying attention
here's barzel in tight he shoots he scores Matt
borzel Kopitar back to the point Roy across
Jersey shots [Music] [Applause] for the Rangers
primarily in penalty killing brat one-on-one brat
twisting finds Hamilton he scores
Dougie Hamilton an overtime game winner
quick shots
a lot of history here in Philadelphia now
Peak moving in fires and shot scores Andrew
Peak with a great individual effort and it's a
one goal game with 8 49 left had two shots on
their first opportunity hence to back toe drag
race shot Jamie Ben steps one home they create
a lot of chances it's just the finishing sleeping
scores wow we are tied in the third ghosts [Music]
[Applause] Niels Lundquist walk in the blue
line goes to the backhand now he chips it
and he scores what a goal it's pretty hard
to [Applause] um [Music] [Applause] [Music]
takes a look shoots scores mcdava posted
in on the power play previous Rodriguez
has been very active this period McDermott
towards the net to his own player [Applause]
ten to eight the shots to favor the Sharks
Fishers and Fisher suits and scores what a
stretch pass and the coyotes have taken a 2-1
lead Edmond walks away drops around to kuchera
they get a good drop Edmonds [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] stays on his feet
Michael back across star Marsha soul the golden
knights have their first lead of game three off
of his stick and now the Stars want to send
Robertson gets angled by Nemeth keeps it on
his stick turns he scores she didn't Robertson
just graze the outside of the post on the glove
side now he's Cuts in front again doing laps in
the San Jose Zone Queen you shoot your scores
[Music] [Applause]
back his first as a New York
Islander drops it to McAvoy closes
anyway we're still on the ice for Carolina last
minute of overtime scores in overtime feel the
burn Carolina takes it nice move on forsling
Skinner continues to drive down towards the net
but forsling stays with him Thompson to Skinner
Skinner tough angle shot scores what a goal by
Jeff Skinner wow deep in the attacking Zone ah
the power play now here's O'Reilly [Applause]
second power play for Edmonton but David
looking to tie it right here [Applause]
a real placement over the right shoulder of
jari overtime Jarvis now his feet backing off
Ottawa into the senator Zone [Applause] [Music]
held by cudra makes one move dishes off Stan goes
in back to Couture scores with
points number 100. [Applause]
feeling good and ready to go tonight good
Skating here by Connor he'll cut Keys it up
short score [Applause] reflected that
one while he was hovering in the slot
cross ice well that's good from skate to
stick he scores another brilliant kick up
from the grade eight this one pushed to
the center circle and smetchnikov steps
right in over the line with them the shot got
it back and he hit the post it's in he scores
[Applause]
Suzuki in shoot score Nick Suzuki power
play goal it's 2-1 Montreal shots are
dead even 14 apiece here's Hughes
playing with all kinds of confidence
Jack Hughes you've got to be kidding me